what is it that makes a salesperson
creepy and why aren't you creepy what is
it that that sales is over right it's
structuring a conversation increase the
likelihood that the person who's on the
other side gives you money what does
that mean when two people interact two
frames Collide there is a decision of
who's Alpha the alpha is also contextual
you can be Alpha the president United
States is Alpha everywhere until he goes
into a doctor's offices he tells him to
pull his ass the ability to hold the
frame for most salespeople is having a
clear agenda and controlling the
conversation which is why are we here
the biggest advantage that a salesman
has is that the person that's already
said they have a problem you said you
needed help I'm here how can I help you
and then from that point we have to turn
the desire into a decision you say you
want these things here's the frame that
I want to give you to analyze the
decision can we agree to this Frame
giving Clarity to someone on a decision
is tremendous value